j'ai l'honneur
au nom du Gouvernement de la République
de demander à l'Assemblée nationale
l'abolition de la peine de mort en
France et puisque vous avez prononcé
tout à l'heure le nom de deux condamnés
à mort et de deux exécutés je vous dirai
pourquoi est-ce que plus aucun autre je
sais qu'il n'y a pas dans la peine de
mort de valeur dissuasive sachez bien
que dans la foule qui a trois criait au
passage de buffet de bon temps autour du
palais de justice à mort plus frais Amar
bon temps se trouvait un jeune homme qui
s'appelait Patrick Henry croyez moi à ma
stupéfaction quand je l'ai appris j'ai
compris ce que ce jour-là pouvait
signifier la valeur dissuasive de la
peine de mort
[Applaudissements]